a craven the hunter movie is finally on
the prowl Sony has debuted the first
trailer for the newest entry in its line
of Spider-Man related films so it's time
to track down all the movie connections
and comic nods on this flicks Trail in
the comics Craven Powers up with a
special herbal cocktail that boosts his
physical attributes far beyond normal
while the upper limits of his strength
are by no means at Spider-Man's level he
can definitely hold his own against many
other super-powered folks strength wise
live-action adaptations of comic book
characters might not always share the
exact power set of their print
counterparts but from the looks of it
Taylor Johnson's Craven will be roughly
as fast agile and Powerful as the comics
one in the trailer we see him chase a
car that's attempting to speed away in
reverse then jump on top of it and tear
his way in the Superhuman Feats on
display seem to be roughly in the same
ballpark as the character's traditional
powers and since the trailer also makes
clear that Craven has greatly enhanced
senses we just might be looking at a
very faithful adaptation at least in
this particular respect while the
trailer suggests that Craven's powers
are similar to the comic book version
the way he acquires them seems to be
pretty far removed from what fans are
used to instead of the herbal serum that
gives him powers in the comics the
implication here seems to be that Craven
gets his power boost from Lion blood as
young Craven hunts a lion with his
father he hesitates to fire his weapon
and the animal mulls the boy as the
injured Craven lies on the ground a drop
of the Lion's Blood Falls in one of his
open wounds jump starting something that
seems to revive him and give him
superpowers an accidental blood
transfusion with a large cat seems like
an odd origin story to say the least it
seems that the trailer is deliberately
missing a few steps in the process
possibly to avoid revealing major plot
points or hey maybe the lion just
happens to be radioactive it's clear
from the initial trailer that Craven the
hunter is leaning hard into the family
drama element of its titular character's
backstory and it seems his father isn't
the only blood relative he'll be at odds
with indeed audiences get their first
peek at Craven's half-brother Dimitri a
character far better known for his alter
ego as Spider-Man's super villain the
chameleon in the trailer fans learned
the character doesn't approve of his
half-brother's brutal Quest For Justice
indicating that he may have stronger
moral fiber than his comic book
counterpart while the trailer doesn't
include a look at the chameleon's
trademark skills as a Master of Disguise
reports from deadline and other outlets
indicates that the character delves
headfirst into the Persona at some point
in the movie of course Craven the hunter
is already dealing with a laundry list
of antagonists so it remains to be seen
just how extensive of a role the
face-changing villain plays in this film
in any case viewers would do well to
second guess whether certain characters
are really themselves on screen or if
it's chameleon impersonating them if
there's one Spider-Man villain with an
exceptionally spotty track record in
cinema it's the Rhino this be Behemoth
of a foe has appeared a few times in
various movies with a version portrayed
by Paul Giamatti briefly popping up in
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 and a couple of
multiversal variations getting cameos in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse but
audiences haven't really gotten a chance
to see the character rise as a
legitimate villainous threat however the
first trailer for Craven the hunter
indicates that the movie may be giving
him a bigger Spotlight this time around
along with on some level returning him
to his comic book Roots the final
moments of the trailer introduce
audiences to Alessandro navola's take on
the Rhino so viewers don't get to see
him go full beast mode they do witness
him activate his powers by way of a
self-applied injection giving him his
signature tough gray armor this sequence
shows a rhino a bit closer to the
original Comics conception rather than
the giant robot suit that Giamatti wore
in the Amazing Spider-Man 2. while the
trailer's Rhino teas may have fans
chomping at the bit for more it's wise
to temper expectations on how many
super-powered Shenanigans the character
will actually get up to in an interview
with The Hollywood Reporter navola said
that he only transforms at the very end
of the film based on his quote it seems
that this scene may actually come from
the film's conclusion thereby setting a
full-fledged Rhino up for a craven the
hunter sequel Sony's Marvel movies have
generally delved into darker and more
graphic subject matter than their Marvel
Cinematic Universe equivalents but the
films have nonetheless remained firmly
rooted in PG-13 territory that's what
made it rather surprising when Craven
actor Aaron Taylor-Johnson revealed at
cinemacon 2023 that Craven the hunter
would land a strong R rating fans may
have had their doubts but the trailer
definitively puts any skepticism on that
front to rest throughout the trailer
audiences see Craven take out a number
of hired henchmen and spectacularly gory
fashion throats are sliced necks are
stabbed and chests are shot through with
crossbows the lead even bites off part
of a guy's face at one point just to
really Hammer the point home that yes
Craven the hunter isn't pulling any
punches with its bloody brand of
violence oh and the trailer shows a
young Craven getting mauled by a lion so
toss graphic child Peril on the list of
definitely not PG-13 stuff in here too
most movies adapted from comic books
alter things here and there to adjust
the property from the page to the screen
sometimes in the interest of telling a
good story writers and filmmakers will
alter the origins or setting of a
character in this case the writers went
a bit further and appear to have
fundamentally altered the core
motivations of the character in the
trailer we see that Craven is hunting
for one reason
my father puts evil into the world
I take it out
since this is an origin story we can
assume this mostly occurs before he
turns into the brutish Hunter hellbent
on catching his most pursued prey
Spider-Man however in the comics Craven
is a depraved man beaten in childhood by
his alcoholic father and two in turn
beats his half-brother he turns to big
game hunting and downs every coveted
animal on his list before turning his
attention to Spider-Man since the
superhero represents the animal that
haunted his dreams since his mother's
time in an asylum it becomes a personal
mission while there are shreds of that
origin represented in the trailer like
his father as a villain being tormented
by spiders and so on the film seems to
be taking the anti-hero approach to the
famous Spider-Man antagonist is Craven
destined for a showdown with Spider-Man
that remains to be seen But the trailer
for his upcoming Solo movie does tease
the Hunter's obsession with the friendly
neighborhood superhero toward the end of
the teaser Craven is shown lying on the
ground as spiders Rush toward him from
the trees the sequence might help to
remind viewers that this is a Spider-Man
universe movie but it might also reveal
more about Craven's psyche the scene is
clearly done in homage to Marvel's
Craven's last Hunt storyline this tale
Chronicles the titular villain's
attempts to dispose of Spidey and take
his place and it's widely regarded as
one of the best stories in Spider-Man
history furthermore the scene in the
trailer is a reference to web of
Spider-Man number 31 which features a
panel that depicts Craven munching on
arachnids as they cover his entire body
is the Craven the hunter trailer trying
to tell us that this version of the
character will also be hell-bent on
eating Spider-Man down the line with a
piece of Venom symbiote now in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe alongside
Peter Parker Anything is Possible
while it hasn't officially been
confirmed yet seemingly everyone knows
that Ariana Dubose is set to play
Calypso in Craven the hunter however if
there are still any lingering doubts
about that fact the teaser should clear
them up in the comics Calypso is a
voodoo priestess and Craven's love
interest she takes great Delight in
nurturing his Psychopathic Tendencies
and fueling his hatred of Spider-Man to
a troubling extent so at least they've
got hobbies in common however if Sony
insists on turning Craven into a
sympathetic anti-hero for his big
on-screen outing it makes sense to give
Calypso a more light-hearted makeover as
well the trailer implies that dubose's
character will be on the protagonist's
side which only lends Credence to the
rumors that she's playing some version
of the voodoo priestess furthermore
Calypso often Sports a gold necklace
around her neck similar to the one to
both swears in the Craven the hunter
trailer while it was impressive when the
studio booked Aaron Taylor-Johnson for
the Craven the hunter lead Sony also
locked in on another compelling name
from the indie film realm for a
potentially major supporting role in
Christopher Abbott Abbott's role has yet
to be confirmed but rumors abound he's
playing Spidey foe The Foreigner perhaps
best known for his roles in HBO's girls
and the 2019 mini-series Catch-22 Abbott
has also wowed in projects like it comes
at night first man and possessor Craven
is undoubtedly his biggest film to date
and if Abbott is playing the Foreigner
in the Blockbuster he'll no doubt bring
something unique to the mix fans would
probably not call The Foreigner a major
Spider-Man Baddie but he's probably best
known for once being married to fellow
mercenary silver Sable but minor
villains have gotten big movie roles in
the past c-lister the spot was the key
villain in across the spiderverse after
all it remains to be seen how big a role
The Foreigner might play in Craven the
Hunter
after giving a look at Craven's origin
most of the trailer is dedicated to
showing how many different people the
grown-up version of Sergey can kill but
one element of the character sticking
out like a sore thumb is sergey's Manner
of speech because he appears to have an
American accent that shouldn't be the
case given that his entire family is
Russian a detail that's been preserved
from the comics as we hear his father
speak in a Russian accent multiple times
during the first half of the trailer
power is about sex
future weakness and you will give our
enemies an opening perhaps Craven was
shipped off to a boarding school where
one could assume he picked up his
American accent if that's the case it's
unclear whether he was shipped off to
the boarding school before or after the
accident that gives him his powers but
by the time he's a teenager Sergey
speech is clearly not with a Russian
accent
all right because she sent her away
Craven the hunter is the next chapter of
Sony's Spider-Man less Spidey verse so
it makes sense for there to be some
connections to Venom and morbius the
trailer does seem to connect to one
unseen character first mentioned in the
first Venom a man enters an office to
see Mr taglin unfortunately Craven's
already killed Mr taglin and shoots the
man with a crossbow it certainly seems
like Mr taglin was important
Mr tagline
Mr tackling
where's Mr tagley another tagline was
referenced in venom in that movie Lee
taglin is an employee at mikalini and
McFarland who works with Anne weighing
Eddie Brock's ex-fiancee this is the law
firm that represents the foundation
responsible for capturing the Symbiotes
one of which was Venom it's possible
that the Mr taglin whom Craven killed is
the same one who worked with Anne after
all why focus on the name so much or
perhaps it's someone who's related to
Lee taglan or an entirely different
person either way a connection certainly
seems likely especially given how often
the name is mentioned in the scene
thank you